-Performing their single
"Make You Say,"
give it up for
Zedd and Maren Morris.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ You'll miss the weeks,
the days, the hours ♪
♪ When all the loneliness
kicks in ♪
♪ You'll buy them drinks
and send them flowers ♪
♪ But they won't love you
like I did ♪
♪ You'll learn one day ♪
♪ I'm one in a million ♪
♪ Maybe in a billion ♪
♪ And when it's too late ♪
♪ Oh, I got a feelin' ♪
♪ You'll be in your feelings ♪
♪ Go ahead, walk away ♪
♪ You're gonna miss the way
I used to make you say ♪
♪ Oh, my God, night and day ♪
♪ You're gonna miss the way
I used to make you say ♪
♪♪
♪ We had some highs and lows
and in-betweens ♪
♪ We could've stayed
and worked it out ♪
♪ You got your arms around her
when you sleep ♪
♪ But I'm the one
you dream about ♪
-♪ You'll learn one day ♪
♪ I'm one in a million ♪
-♪ I'm one in a million ♪
-♪ Maybe in a billion ♪
--♪ Maybe in a billion ♪
-♪ And when it's too late ♪
-♪ Too late ♪
-♪ Oh, I got a feelin' ♪
-♪ You'll be in your feelings ♪
-♪ You'll be in your feelings,
babe ♪
♪ Go ahead, walk away ♪
♪ You're gonna miss the way
I used to make you say ♪
♪ Oh, my God, night and day ♪
♪ You're gonna miss the way
I used to make you say ♪
♪♪
♪ Oh-oh-oh-oh, oh-oh-oh-oh,
oh-oh-oh-oh ♪
♪♪
♪ Oh-oh-oh-ohhhhh ♪
♪ Go ahead, walk away ♪
♪♪
♪ Oh, my God, night and day ♪
♪ Go ahead, walk away ♪
♪ You're gonna miss the way
I used to make you say ♪
♪ Oh, my God, night and day ♪
♪ You're gonna miss the way
I used to make you saaaaaaay ♪
♪ Ohhhh ♪
♪ Oh-ohhhh ♪
♪ Make you saaaaay ♪
♪ Go ahead, walk away ♪
♪ You're gonna miss the way
I used to make you say ♪
♪ Oh, my God, night and day ♪
♪ You're gonna miss the way
I used to make you say ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]